hola bueno pues en nuestro último vídeo
nosotros estuvimos aproximando el área
bajo una curva utilizando rectángulos
donde la altura de dichos rectángulos
fue definida por el límite izquierdo de
nuestra función evaluada en dicho límite
así que había sido nuestro primer
rectángulo y luego así hicimos nuestro
segundo rectángulo y así hasta que
llegamos a un enésimo rectángulo que son
representados en la misma forma
y luego nosotros también vimos que como
estos rectángulos iban desde el 1 hasta
el n tomamos la suma de las áreas de
dichos rectángulos entonces dicha suma
que obtuvimos para aproximar nuestra
área bajo la curva que va desde igual a
1 hasta nuestro enésimo rectángulo nos
dio esencialmente nuestra aproximada la
cual la fuimos calculando primero
teniendo nuestra base multiplicada por
nuestra altura donde nuestra altura
representada en el primer caso la
función evaluada en x0 y para el segundo
rectángulo sería la función evaluada en
x 1 y así sucesivamente hasta que el
límite de la altura de nuestro
rectángulo enésimo será la función
evaluada en x n menos 1 así que la
altura del rectángulo
hablar en términos generales sería la
función evaluada en x y menos 1 pues
como ves si tenemos al rectángulo 2
nuestra función se evalúa en x 1 nuestra
nuestra función para el rectángulo 2
evaluada en x 1 y entonces esto es para
cuando hablamos de límite izquierdo
ahora habría que multiplicar por nuestra
base la cual la definimos por delta x
que simplemente era la diferencia de el
total del intervalo b - se divide entre
el número total de intervalos que
queríamos entonces multiplicamos nuestra
función evaluada en el límite izquierdo
por delta equis y bueno tú me podrás
decir esta no es la única forma de poder
calcular nuestra área bajo la curva no
son solamente utilizando rectángulos o
podemos usar otro tipo de figuras
geométricas o bien me podrás decir bueno
usemos rectángulos pero a usted usemos
ahora para determinar nuestra altura
vamos a utilizar nuestro límite
entonces aquí tendríamos f x 1 sería
nuestra función 1 luego nuestro segundo
rectángulo nuestra altura la definiría x
2 y así otra vez con la misma idea
tenemos nuestro enésimo rectángulo el
cual su altura estará definida como
podrás ver por aquí nuestro enésimo
rectángulo su altura estará definida a
diferencia de lo anterior estamos
tomando el límite derecho entonces sería
para x n y entonces esto sería la suma
para calcular nuestra área debajo de
dicha curva desde igual a uno hasta n de
cada uno de nuestras funciones evaluadas
en el límite derecho entonces cómo ves
la altura del primer rectángulo es x1 y
la altura de nuestro enésimo rectángulo
la define el límite de hecho x n
entonces es la función evaluada en dicho
límite derecho entonces para términos
generales el décimo rectángulo sería la
función evaluada en xy por delta x cuál
es la diferencia entre esta primera y la
que tenemos de nuestro lado derecho bien
pues la simple diferencia que hay es que
para nuestra primera para nuestro primer
ejemplo lo que nosotros hicimos fue
utilizar el límite izquierdo entonces
eso hacía que para el 20º evaluamos la
función en x menos 1 y en el derecho era
en x pero bueno también podemos decir
que no nos vamos a quedar ahí ahora
podemos definir que sea el punto medio
nuestra altura la defina el punto medio
entre nuestros dos límites entonces esto
de aquí sería efe de x 0 + x 1 sobre 2
simplemente el punto medio entre estas
dos partes nos definen nuestra altura
sería simplemente nuestro punto medio y
aquí tenemos la altura de nuestro primer
rectángulo luego aquí calculamos el
punto medio de nuestro segundo
rectángulo y así sucesivamente otra vez
hasta llegar a nuestro enésimo
rectángulo calculamos el punto medio el
cual sería la suma de x en nuestro
límite derecho más x en el -1 nuestro
límite izquierdo sobre 2 entonces nos
queda así y esto sería fx n más x menos
1 sobre 2 entonces en términos generales
tenemos que sería la suma para calcular
toda nuestra área sería la suma desde
igual a uno hasta n que son el total de
nuestros rectángulos y nos observamos
otra vez que aquí seguimos un patrón
entonces simplemente aquí volvemos a
evaluar nuestra función en el punto
medio entonces sería en y menos 1 + xy
sobre 2 y hay que multiplicar también
por la base que la base vuelve a ser
exactamente la misma delta x y ahora sí
esta sería la forma de calcular nuestra
área debajo de la curva aproximadamente
para este ejemplo finalmente pasemos a
un último ejemplo veamos cómo podemos
definirlo aquí bueno pues como lo había
dicho anteriormente no es nada más
necesario trabajar con rectángulos
entonces qué te parece si trabajamos con
trapecios donde aquí es la parte
izquierda de nuestro trapecio nuestra
parte derecha de nuestro trapecio estará
definida por efe x1 la izquierda de f de
x0 y esta línea es la que une nuestro
trapecio entonces luce algo así nuestro
segundo trapecio vemos que tiene una
altura casi paralela o casi plana y
finalmente nos seguimos así hasta llegar
a nuestro enésimo trapecio a nuestro
enésimo trapecio donde vemos que es
mucho más inclinada a su altura y bien
ahora como calculamos el área de un
trapecio bueno pues simplemente
recordemos cómo se hacía esto era el
promedio de las alturas y luego a esta
hora multiplicamos por la base entonces
sería de la siguiente forma digamos que
para nuestro primer trapecio
para nuestro primer trapecio nuestra
área será la siguiente entonces entonces
tenemos que sea la función evaluada en
x0 más f de x 1 y todo esto sobre 2 para
representar el promedio de las alturas y
todo esto multiplicado por delta x que
es nuestra base y es la misma para todos
los escenarios y bueno esto es hablando
para nuestro primer trapecio pero ahora
si queremos calcular en términos
generales el área de la bueno la suma de
estas áreas para tener el área
aproximada de nuestra curva de nuestra
área bajo la curva será la suma desde
igual hasta igual a uno hasta n de
nuestros n trapecios de el promedio de
la siguiente parte sea la función
evaluada para el décimo trapecio de nx y
menos uno más la función evaluada en xy
todo esto sobre dos para el promedio y
multiplicado por delta x
bien y pues la gran razón por lo que yo
quise mostrarte esto en sí es para que
veas como existen múltiples y múltiples
formas de realizarlo de hecho si quieres
hacerlo realmente genial podemos
realizarlo pero quizás un tanto confuso
entonces pues yo quise mostrarte para
cuando tenemos el caso de que hay
trapecios o puedes utilizar el punto
medio entre los límites de los
rectángulos o en este caso que usamos el
límite derecho o el límite izquierdo
cualquiera que te hubiera gustado para
cualquier forma